so some friends tell you about something
called ayahuasca improv
you know enough not to tell me cuz
because you're afraid I'll talk you out
of it absolutely so you get over to Peru
it's like 300 hours together yeah and
then they say you know we have a shaman
here who wants to read cocoa leaves coca
leaves for you no what are you doing
here you're insane Howard I walk into
the room where the Masters cuz they say
okay now it's time for your ayahuasca
ceremony oh they bring me into this room
they're mats and pillows lining the
walls but there are two buckets in the
room so then the master starts to
explain to me he says you are going to
get sick but don't worry about it
everybody does
so the bucket is here for you to vomit
it what you said you know what I'm not
interested in vomiting so finally after
he prays and you know he meditates and
he reads the coca leaves he says now
it's time for you to take la medicina
open this stuff and it starts foaming
it's like this ugly brown liquid oh my
god out of that look at it it looks
horrible it is the worst tasting stuff
you could ever imagine so as soon as you
taste it you don't want to do anything
more and he's like no drinking up
drinking up drinking up so I gulp it
down and then they said watch you right
because with these people don't speak
English and they watch it did anything
happen I'm as sick as a dog
you're nuts that I'm also you just can't
stop it just keep going and going
she's good somebody's there massaging my
shoulders going it's gonna be okay it's
gonna be okay and then when you finally
get all of this stuff out of you you lay
back down on this mat and you start to
have vision vision to see all of the
misery of the world
[Applause]
I cried probably for about four hours
I mean weeping and what's master doing
during this Wow that was only the first
night what was the second vision what
did you learn I learned that life is
great except for all the stuff that
sucks Wow and everything you got to go
all the way for that am I talking to a
new Ravi I am I am very very pleasantly
surprised that I came home feeling great
Fred what do you make of this Wow she
won't drink milk right right this [ __ ]
she'll drink right it's like [ __ ]
turpentine was laced with like you know
well what she's you know it's me [ __ ]
you know she went and she's legally
absolutely no sense and she's not a drug
person right and down now she's gonna
base our whole life on this
hallucination
yeah you'll see anything if you get hurt
un-fuckin'-believable